elles sont quatre maires du québec 5 de
l'ontario et une de
l'île-du-prince-édouard avoir échangé
ces derniers jours des dizaines de
messages électroniques et de textos au
sujet d'une situation qui les
préoccupent
l'intimidation à l'école leur histoire
ou plutôt celle de leurs enfants sont
tristement similaires pendant des mois
voire des années
il aurait été victime d'intimidation
leurs parents ont récemment pris
conscience que ce que leurs enfants
vivent et n'était pas unique
et puis là-bas c'est un grand cri du
coeur qu'on essaie de faire puis on
s'aperçoit que c'est un peu partout la
même chose
ses parents ont donc décidé d'unir leurs
efforts en rédigeant une lettre adressée
au premier ministre roselyne goulet n'a
pas hésité un instant à signer cette
lettre
j'espérais que ça n'arriverait pas
jusqu'au point est aujourd'hui mais nous
sommes là on veut délais avec avoir
travaillé ensemble pour régler conflit
pour que ça n'arrive plus jamais cette
mère d'un enfant qui souffre d'un
trouble de l'autisme est persuadé que
son fils a été victime d'un acte
d'intimidation
il a subi une fracture du fémur à
l'école la commission scolaire de langue
française et la police de charlton
refuse de parler d'intimidation dans ce
cas ci
certaines écoles au pays ne sont pas
prête à reconnaître les situations
d'intimidation croit ce groupe de mer il
ya de la règlement qu'on peut considérer
volontaires également de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle et un manque de moralité
dynaction des écoles et conseil ou
commission scolaire et des gouvernements
provinciaux les incite à se tourner vers
justin trudeau
dans cette lettre la coalition de
parents demandent au premier ministre de
faire pression sur les gouvernements
provinciaux afin qu'ils appliquent les
lois et seize de les contourner
pour l'ontario ni trop nuls dont le fils
a préféré changer d'école pour ne plus
faire intimider
il est temps qu'on agisse en haut lieu
le stornext ap
et c'est marc espèrent que leur lettre
adressée au premier ministre arrivera
faire bouger les choses ici dix amants
du flore en radio canada toronto